Li b hiện những tháng có gió buồn luôn làm một tưởng thích lớn
giữ hối gên đảo nhưng ai cũng phải tận thật
chỉ một số xuất nỏ, và nạn có thể sẽ ra
trước đà một trị chính nội của tị trứa
đảo và trang bị íc không có phương rân xin sống
lúc đó chỉ toàn đà một đội
sau hàng chục năm nỗ lực không mừng
rời đảo đã có điện
có dân có chừng học
mòn ổ tổ lượng cũng đã được xây dịch
để bà con như dân vàng chú bảo
có những số ngồi anh thì
chúng ta có 3 chúng ta có xỉnh đảo
chỉ chỉ ra gác
họ khăn trở từ find bước thách bir cakap trở
còn trình cũng phải trặng nhé
chỉ trương khăn trình rất nhiều
không phải chứ gì hải con nào cũng giống có tầu
có mùl lực lượng chỉ con
công táp trên mới và nguy
đó là những chứ gì hải cuôn
cũng các trạm ra ra trên đến
tại mà các ạng ví
Chạm ra ra hay bài có những buồn quan sát của tòa nè mặt biệt.
Chào con sát mà hãy có lực bố,
nói là không mẹ tìm là mạng,
có không cái động lực,
sĩa là học xuân ra đình.
Mà cái nơi chế nấu thì có chất dạ.
Bảm biển, bám đạo,
bảo vệ chủ kiền,
bây giờ là dạy chế đạo của quốc,
thì chúng tôi có một nghiệp tên không để tổ quốc,
thì có thể ngờ chúng ta sẽ giảm cho biac,
một món khăn tất cả của hạn bệnh tốt.
Bình cạnh việc kiểm tra của tắc sát sát xin đấu.
Điều một ngoan công tám rất truyền,
là mang đến cho những cái buổi trị see ở đạo xa,
thì khu khí của tất nhiên,
bởi có hậu phương bước mạnh thì tiền tuyến mởi nhiên tâm công tác.
Đây là chính hải trình,
gọi người yêu vô cùng to lượng,
mang kê em của đất liền,
với tham và trúc tế tất quan và dân nơi hải đạo xa xôi.
Đây là tình cảm,
và chất nghiệm của chính người liến hải quan chúng tôi,
và mong rằng,
cái tình cảm và chính nhạc ấy,
nằm ngồn của vũ đồng viên vô cùng to lượng,
đối với quan và dân,
tạo bệnh nông viên,
nơi hướng tiền tiêu phía đồng bắt của tổ quốc,
đoàn kết thống rất,
để cùng một chúng tôi,
bảo vệ quốc chắc chủ quyền đạo của tổ quốc.
Bà,
bà là khu các hai,
các chiếc hải quân đạo có một ngày thật nhiều ý nghĩa,
không chỉ từ tay trình bị đón tết,
phần ngoài bánh trưng của các anh có sự hỗ trợ của các bạn học sinh tru học.
Nếu không có tình gió có tình giống,
thì a của mình đang ở dưới đất liền.
Đây là lần đầu tiên,
sau đó bây giờ,
để tham đàn tình cảm xúc xa,
và mình chương,
thì sau đó là vui và,
ở nổi,
thì là có một cách xúc,
là một tên được gọi,
và một mọi người.
Môi chính cũng tắc,
thì kìm tra và sự thích các đảo,
mang lại,
thì chiều cảm xúc,
với những chiếc xí ở nơi đạo 3,
và bình là vui chiếc xe chè,
dần đầu tổ quốc.
Các anh có thể sau ra tình năm đầu tiên,
dùng đàn ở xúc thí gạng,
và sự phần tâm.
vậy, chạy có dắt theo dấu đ tint.
Vìi em gợi.
Vìi em gợi ngồi lời đi ngồi ngồi gợi ngồi nga.
Mình xong đó vui, bạc gìa suchi đe khỏi anh.
Dạ không nhiều nhỉ, hấp dẫn dạ.